Guten Morgen, Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ja, herzlich willkommen, hier ist äh Lokbuch Netzpolitik und wie ihr schon auf den ersten Metern äh bemerkt hat, äh
fehlt heute äh jemand, nämlich äh der Linus, der hat sich jetzt mal ein bisschen frei genommen und äh wird hier für ein, zwei Folgen mal das Ganze aus der Ferne äh betrachten, aber äh wir haben hier für ausreichend äh Ersatz gesorgt. Und ich sage jetzt noch mal hallo zu
Thomas, Thomas Luninger.
Hallo, grüß dich Tim.
So und du bist äh ja normalerweise ähm hätte ich jetzt mal gesagt,
Wir schalten nach Wien, in unser österreichisches Studio, aber äh no more.
Ja, jetzt kannst du nach Brüssel schalten. Ähm hier gibt's auch ein Podcast-Studio, weil ich habe meins mitgenommen. Und äh ich bin jetzt im Büro von Edri, European Digital Rights, weil dort arbeite ich jetzt.
Genau, das ist nämlich sozusagen die Neuigkeit, du hast da äh ja nicht unbedingt die Fronten gewechselt, aber zumindest den ähm
den die Beschäftigungsorganisation. Äh wer's noch nicht so mitbekommen hat, du warst schon einige Male zu Gast und hast dich ja schon äh längere Zeit äh in Österreich.
Mit äh verschiedensten netzpolitischen Themen beschäftigt, äh einen großen Schwerpunkt gab's immer, äh war zumindest meine Wahrnehmung, schon immer bei äh Netzneutralität,
oder? Genau und das ist jetzt eigentlich auch das Thema, was dich nach Brüssel geführt hat, weil äh Edri gesagt hat, willst du nicht mal in Europa wohnen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was haben sie denn gesagt? Oder hast du dich beworben?
Nee, ich habe mich nicht beworben. Das war irgendwie so ähm aus der Situation heraus, dass diese EU-Verordnung zur Netzneutalität nicht allen, die damit beschäftigt sind, sehr viel Kopfschmerzen bereitet und schlaflose Nächte,
und äh halt auch, wie alle NGOs ähm immer viel zu wenig Leute hat. Und ähm
die einfach jemanden brauchten, der da aushilft in dem Thema und nachdem ich schon ganz lange Netzertralität mache und auch die Verordnung schon seit Anfang an begleite
Haben Sie mich gefragt, ob ich nicht mal für so zwei Monate bis das Teil durchs Parlament durch ist nach Brüssel kommen will, um für sie zu arbeiten?
Und äh ja, dann habe ich irgendwie äh nachdem ich diese Nachricht bekommen habe, ähm,
Job gekündigt, den ich seit sechseinhalb Jahren hatte, als Programmierer in Wien alle Zelte abgebrochen und bin nach Brüssel gezogen für,
zwei Monate ein bisschen mehr als zwei Monate, um,
das was vorher mein Hobby war an Aktivismus jetzt als Beruf hier in Brüssel ganz nah am Parlament weiterzumachen.
Hm, zwei Monate ist aber jetzt nicht gerade eine besonders ausufernde Perspektive.
Ja, wie es danach weitergeht, ist auch noch ein großes Fragezeichen, das äh langsam auch größer wird am Horizont, aber.
Ähm es war auch irgendwie so äh meine Perspektive, dass diese EU-Verordnung, wenn man da nichts macht, halt einfach ganz klar den Bach runtergeht.
Und äh deswegen wollte ich da auch einfach wirklich diese Chance mal ergreifen, einerseits da mitzuhelfen, dass da
unsere Perspektive, die netzpolitische Perspektive bisschen stärker vertreten wird und gleichzeitig ist das auch genau der Job, den ich eigentlich machen will im Leben und deswegen
war das so ein bissel ein da ins kalte Wasser zu springen.
Dann findet sich hoffentlich danach ein neuer Job oder vielleicht hier irgendwas im Anschluss, das werden wir sehen.
Mhm. Okay, mutig, mutig, aber finde ich gut.
Da haben wir jetzt zumindest äh für für bestimmte Zeit äh unseren Korrespondenten in äh Brüssel und das wollten wir dann jetzt hier auch gleich in der ersten Sendung mal äh nutzen, denn
Netzpolitik ist
Netzneutralität, ja, ist eins der heißen Themen, du hast es ja schon angesprochen und wir haben das ja hier auch schon äh ein paar Mal äh entsprechend begleitet und auch vor allem auf die
ähm nicht nur von Idri, aber ich glaube von vor allem von Edri vorangetriebene safe the Internet dot EU Kampagne hingewiesen.
Ja, also die Safety Internet EU ist so irgendwie ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt von eigentlich allen großen europäischen Netzpolitikorganisationen, also ähm wir haben das so in Österreich aus äh programmiert als Netzfreiheit
und ähm da waren aber immer schon die dabei,
war ziemlich früh dabei und Edri und Access Now haben das sozusagen
Von der Policy-Ebene hier aus Brüssel begleitet, weil die eben die den Großteil der Arbeit mit dem Parlament und dem lokalen politischen Vertretern machen.
Genau, so und jetzt stand ja äh schon länger an, dass dort eine entsprechende Beschluss äh Fassung erfolgt durch das europäische Parlament. Das läuft ja dann immer durch äh so allerlei äh Ausschüsse, einen Ausschuss, gibt's dann immer, der da im wesentlichen für zuständig ist. Äh wie heißt der nochmal gleich?
Das ist der äh Industrietechnologie und Research, Ausschuss. Und ähm da.
Mhm. Das ist aber der einzige, der sich jetzt bisher noch nicht äh geäußert hat. Alle anderen haben da schon ihr Statement zu abgegeben.
Genau, also eigentlich kann man sich das so wie eine Pyramide vorstellen, dass alle anderen irgendwie dem zuarbeiten, ihrer Meinungen abstimmen?
Und der federführende Ausschuss sollte eigentlich ähm so auf den ähm steht auf diesen anderen, schaut sich alle anderen Ergebnisse an,
und äh führt die dann zusammen zu einem gemeinsamen Ergebnis, was,
ins Plenum geht. In dem Fall haben wir aber leider die Situation, dass alle anderen Ausschüsse sehr netzneutralitätsfreundlich waren,
aber jetzt im Industrieausschuss, der, wie's der Name schon sagt, sehr industriefreundlich ist
sich das Blatt nochmal wendet und wir die Gefahr haben, dass das ganze nochmal kippt und wir uns riesige Probleme einreißen in einigen Punkten der Verordnung.
Das heißt, kippt, also es ist deine eigentliche Einschätzung schon, die das, dass es eine pro Netzneutralität, Grundhaltung gibt im europäischen Parlament.
Ja, also wir hatten in dieser Legislaturperiode von diesen fünf Jahren, die es das Parlament gibt, ähm schon drei Resolutionen für die Netznetralität.
Das Thema war wirklich ganz oft in der Debatte die Parlamentarier kennen das,
es gibt auch schon Dokumente sogar von den Konservativen, wo sie sich für eine Verankerung der Netznetralität und gegen kommerziell motivierte Diskriminierung im Netzwerk aussprechen,
Also ähm jetzt doch mal vor dieser Wahl, mit dem aktuellen Parlament haben wir auf jeden Fall so eine Grundhaltung, die sehr pronetzneutralität ist.
Wie immer bei diesem Thema muss man dann aber auf die Details schauen, weil ähm es sagen eigentlich keine Politiker heutzutage mehr, dass sie gegen der Zentralität sind, so wie auch niemand mehr sagt, dass er gegen Umweltschutz ist,
nur was sie dann im Detail wirklich machen und genau meinen damit, das ist natürlich immer noch die Frage.
Ja. Äh so, das heißt, jetzt kommt dieser letzte äh also der äh der hätte aber eigentlich jetzt diesen Montag Stellung beziehen sollen.
Genau, die hätten eigentlich lange angekündigt ihren Abstimmungstermin am vierundzwanzigsten Februar gehabt.
Und äh dann ist ein ja fast komediantisches Ding passiert. Ähm,
Also die Abstimmung war spät abends in Straßburg und äh es wurde eigentlich äh überhaupt nicht inhaltlich diskutiert. Also waren zwei Punkte auf der Tagesordnung. Eine Richtlinie,
irgendwie weniger äh Plastiksackerl, weniger äh Plastik,
Einkaufstaschen. Äh irgendwie in Europa verpflichtend machen wollte und der zweite Punkt war die Netzneutralität. Und die Konservativen haben dann eine Debatte losgetreten,
dass man nicht über die Plastiksackerl abstimmen darf, weil nicht alle Änderungsanträge äh in allen Sprachen zur Verfügung stehen
was ein wirklicher, ja, blödsinniger Formalgrund ist, den man sonst niemals ins Feld führen würde, aber die Konservativen haben das in diesem Fall gemacht und dann wurde schon mal irgendwie so fast eine Stunde lang, nur darüber diskutiert und gestritten, ob man jetzt drüber abstimmen soll oder nicht.
Aber es gings nicht um die Nestneutralität, sondern um die Kunststoff Kunststofftragetaschen, was, glaube ich, der korrekte Termen ist.
Genau, genau, ja, äh es ist mein österreichischer Hintergrund.
Ja, die hat ja auch jeder sein anderes Wort dafür so. Äh man hätte auch Plastiktüten sagen können, aber ich habe irgendwann mal mit so einem Plastiktüten Produzenten an einem Tisch gesessen und der hat mich sehr nachhaltig belegt, auch dass ich,
Kunststofftragetasche sage, weil die Plastiktüte offensichtlich zu läppisch vorkam.
Kunststofftragetasche. Ich.
Furchtbar, oder? Nenn's einfach, wie du möchtest. Also, Plaste sagt.
Plastiksacker. Ähm und und äh auf jeden Fall, das war schon eine sehr hitzige Debatte, wenn man sich das äh in in der Recruiting anhört, dann,
Ja, wirkt da schon ein bisschen kurios und die Grünen haben dann aber dieses Chaos genutzt und ähm haben.
Das zweite Thema auf der Tagesordnung, die Netzneutralität verbunden damit und haben gesagt, okay, ja, in dem Dossier haben wir aber auch nicht alle Änderungsanträge in allen vierundzwanzig Sprachen,
vorliegen. Das heißt, darüber können wir dann heute auch nicht abstimmen.
Und äh da konnte man irgendwie nicht wirklich so das eine ablehnen, ohne das andere auch abzunehmen und dann,
man eben so eine äh Abstimmung gemacht und da kam raus, dass man heute nichts abstimmen wird, sondern wartet, bis alle Änderungsanträge übersetzt sind.
Oh Mann, welche Fraktion war das nochmal, die denn sich dagegen ausgesprochen hat im zweiten Schritt?
Ähm also im zweiten Schritt, es war eine chaotische Debatte und ab dem Zeitpunkt sind die Wortmeldungen auch äh wirklich nur noch polemisches Politisieren. Da war nicht mehr wirklich ähm,
pro Contra. Äh ich glaube war's von den deutschen Grünen, der das ausgeweitet hat auf die Netzzentralität?
Mhm.
Und äh ja am Ende hat sogar die Berichterstatterin für die Netzneutralität Pilare Castilio für die Vertragung gestimmt.
Aber warum gab's, also ich meine, kann man das jetzt so deuten mit es gab keinen.
Also es gab zumindest keinen breiten Konsens darüber, dass man überhaupt das jetzt ab
gestimmt haben will, also wollte da irgendjemand jetzt noch Zeit gewinnen oder war das jetzt nur so eine Retellation für diese Kleingeistigkeit wegen der Plastiktüten oder was?
Also ich glaube die Logik der Grünen war,
Dass man mehr Zeit gewinnen wollte, weil diese Abstimmung am Montag, die hätten wir verloren. Das muss man klar sagen, äh Castillo hätte eine Mehrheit gehabt, weil die Liberalen sich auf ihre Seite geschlagen haben.
Die Konservativen und die Liberalen haben eine Mehrheit im Europaparlament.
Und äh das bedeutet, sie hätte mit ihrem sehr schlechten Vorschlag ähm die Netzautralität in Europa abgeschafft.
Und äh nachdem die Grünen das verhindern wollten, haben sie sozusagen diesen Kunstgriff gewählt äh um beides jetzt mal nach hinten zu verschieben. Der neue Abstimmungstermin ist der achtzehnte März.
Aha.
Das heißt einerseits für uns, dass wir jetzt mehr Zeit haben im Industrieausschuss, dort noch die Leute zu überzeugen
aber weniger Zeit dann zwischen der Abstimmung im Industrieausschuss und dem Plenum, was am ersten April sein wird, da haben wir irgendwie so.
Noch ein paar Wochen.
Zwei Wochen,
und äh das heißt, dass wir jetzt irgendwie weiter mit den Parlamentariern arbeiten müssen, die wir schon ziemlich heftig bearbeitet haben,
halt wirklich eher jetzt nicht das liberalere sind, sondern wirklich eher die Hardliner Konservativen und Industrienamen,
Und äh dass diese Leute jetzt mal äh eben äh noch weiter über die Netzautralität entscheiden können und.
Ja
nochmal diesen diesen Prozess äh nochmal ein bisschen ähm klarer äh zu machen. Ich habe mich da jetzt auch grad selber nochmal ein bisschen intensiver mit beschäftigt. Also hier geht's ja dadrum, die Initiative ist von der Kommission ausgegangen, das muss ja auch so sein. Äh
äh das quasi über die Netzneutralität äh befunden werden soll und der Kommissionsvorschlag ist schon zwiespaltig.
Genau, der Kommissionsvorschlag ist schon mal so geschrieben, dass er eigentlich ähm also erstmal viel,
viel zu komplex und viel zu verwirrend ist. Ähm jetzt mal, wenn wir uns nur den Teil zur Netzneutralität anschauen, dann äh sind da wirklich so äh Fallstricke eingebaut.
Die man erstmal irgendwie dechiffrieren muss, um drauf zu kommen, dass auch wenn man sich das in den ersten dreimal durchgelest hat und glaubt, das ist jetzt für Netzneutralität, beim vierten und fünften Mal fällt einem auf,
dass das äh eben genau das Gegenteil meint und das ist von Providern irrsinnig gut ausgenutzt werden kann
Und äh wir müssen uns klar sein, äh Telekommunikationsrecht ist eine Sache, ja, da haben wir's mit Telkus zu tun und mit der Produktgestaltung von Telkos. Man kann denen vieles vorwerfen, aber nicht, dass sie unkreativ werden mit ihren Produkten.
Vor allem wenn sie damit Geld machen können und es besonders kompliziert für die User machen wollen.
Genau, fällt da eigentlich in diesem Kommissionsentwurf auch dieser Begriff Managed Services, mit dem die Telekom hier auch ganz gerne hausieren geht?
Nur sie nennen es Special als Service.
Service.
Das ich könnte auch noch irgendwie kurz erklären, wie's zu diesen zwei Begriffen kommt, weil das ist auch ganz lustig. Ähm,
Also, Managed Service ist das, was sich irgendwie was die Telkus äh angefangen haben zu verwenden für die Dienste, die sie managen.
Das sind äh jetzt mal irgendwie, das sind die eigenen Angebote, die wir haben, die wir priorisieren in unseren Netzen. Das sind vielleicht auch die Partnerangebote von den Firmen, die uns Geld zahlen, die wir auch auf die Überholspur lassen,
Das sind die Dienste, die wir managen.
Und dann kam das ist äh das sind die Regulierungsbehörden auf europäischer Ebene. Ist ein sehr cooles Premium, die wirklich sehr zur Versachlichung der ganzen Debatte in Europa beigetragen haben.
Ähm und die
haben ein sehr gutes Papier rausgebracht ähm im äh zweitausendelf Guidelines for
Quality of Service und Network und da haben sie eigentlich schon ein Großteil der Definitionen gebracht, die man heute verwenden sollte in diesem Gesetz. Da haben sie genau gesagt, was ist Netzzentralität, was ist Internet,
Und was ist ein Special-Leist-Service?
Sie haben Specialist Service gewählt, um eben nicht einen Manageservice zu meinen. Sie haben gedacht, ein Special als Service ist wirklich etwas, was nicht Internet ist. Ein Special als Service ist,
etwas, das nichts mit dem Internet zu tun hat, sondern was nur über dieselbe Infrastruktur läuft.
Also wie zum Beispiel SMS.
Genau, wie SMS, äh wie Fernsehen, ähm wie Telefonie an sich, ja, wie äh wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Bankomaten über IP anschließe und das ist aber nicht das Internet.
Der ist jetzt nicht äh ähm oder so, sondern wirklich abgekapselt. Ähm all diese Dienste, die nicht wirklich Internet sind, sondern in geschlossenen,
Zutritts getrennten Systemen betrieben und äh verwaltet werden.
Das sind Special Life Service, die darf man auch äh anders behandeln. Die müssen nicht beste Erfurt sein.
Und die haben sozusagen mit Service klar diese Unterscheidung getroffen.
Jetzt hat die Kommission das Wort verwendet, aber die alte Bedeutung von,
Telekom zum Beispiel, ja? Also die äh Kommission hat Service so definiert, dass darunter auch Spotify fallen würde.
Das ist ein Kern des Problems, mit dem wir hier zu kämpfen.
Ah, verstehe, okay. Also, spulen wir nochmal kurz zurück. Also, das ist jetzt der Vorschlag der Kommission äh gewesen und jetzt ist es ja so, jetzt musst du diesem Vorschlag der Kommission
zwei andere Entitäten nochmal Stellung beziehen. Das ist auf der einen Seite der europäische Rat, also quasi die,
Ne, so die Bundesrat ähnliche äh Vertretung, wo quasi die Regierung äh indirekt repräsentiert sind, der einzelnen äh Länder, also die Mitgliedsländer quasi.
Eben das europäische Parlament und um diese Stellungnahme des Europäischen Parlamentes gegenüber der dieses ursprünglichen.
Bisher einzigen Vorschlags der Kommission um den geht es jetzt gerade und um da aber den Konsens zu finden innerhalb des Parlaments geht es zunächst einmal durch die Ausschüsse und es gibt immer einen Ausschuss der zuständig ist und dessen,
Beschlussfassung ist quasi,
wie soll man sagen, wegweisend, Leitmotiv bildend, das ist so sozusagen, also was dieser ITRI Ausschuss letztlich beschließt, gilt schon so als,
Empfehlung für das Plenum, also für die Gesamtversammlung des Parlaments. Das heißt nicht, dass sie zwingen, dort so abstimmen müssen, aber ich glaube, das ist dann so die Regel, oder?
Genau, also der Fehler für den Ausschuss ist wirklich so
in großen Teilen das was dann am Ende auch im Plenum beschlossen wird weil einfach die meisten Abgeordneten im Plenum sich nicht mit
jeden Dossier beschäftigen. Die haben einfach so viel abzustimmen, dass sie nicht genau hinschauen. Vor allem so nah vor der Wahl. Das ist wirklich die letzte Plenarsitzung
Ähm da kann man nicht davon ausgehen, dass sich sonderlich viele damit beschäftigen werden, außer wir schaffen's wirklich Aktedimensionen noch mit unserer Kampagne zu reisen.
Ich will noch einen Nachsatz bringen zu dem, was du gerade gesagt hast. Es stimmt alles. Es gibt diese drei Institutionen mit Kommission, Rats und Parlament.
Aber aus Bürgerperspektive ist das Parlament eigentlich die einzige Organisation, wo wir überhaupt eine Möglichkeit haben, europäische Politik mitzugestalten.
Die Kommission ist eine riesige Bürokratieapparat,
wo man als normaler Bürger so gut wie überhaupt nicht reinkommt und äh eigentlich vom Gesetzgebungsprozess komplett ausgeschlossen ist. Da fallen Gesetze raus,
Hin und wieder kann man mit Konsultationen Meinungen abgeben, aber im Endeffekt handeln die komplett autonom an und und sind losgelöst von allem anderen
Ähm der Europarat, die Vertretung der Länder. Ähm da haben wir als Bürger auch eigentlich überhaupt keine wirkliche Möglichkeit, hauptsächlich, weil alle unsere Regierungen sich halt immer ausreden auf, ja das war die EU, das waren doch nicht wir.
Und ähm auch wenn die alle dafür mitgestimmt haben, ähm ist es leider so, dass wir im Europarat,
auch mit Bürgerinitiativen, mit Kampagnen, so gut wie überhaupt keine Chance haben, was zu bewegen. Es ist wirklich nur das Europaparlament, wo wir ähm als als Zivilgesellschaft ähm uns Gehör verschaffen können,
wo die Prozesse auch einigermaßen offen und transparent sind und man nachvollziehen kann, wer jetzt wann, über was entscheidet und was Verhandlungsstand ist,
das sind alles Dinge, wo man nicht mal von träumen könnte in den anderen europäischen Institutionen.
So, jetzt hat sich ja äh Edri, wie wir schon gemerkt haben, äh sehr eingeklingt, gab da auch so einige äh Blog-Beiträge von Edri recht scharf äh züngiger Natur, ja, die wie zum Beispiel hier, wo die Kommission, also wo der Kommission vorgeworfen wird, das Europäische Parlament
äh da auszumanövern, was was steckt da dahinter? Also.
Ja, also ähm was wir halt jetzt sehen, ist, dass ähm alle Parlamentarier ja eigentlich eh für die Netzneutralität sind. Und jetzt,
lasst uns da jetzt haben wir lang genug drüber geredet, jetzt lasst uns endlich das beschließen, weil wir wollen auch das abschaffen und ähm man will jetzt irgendwie schnell machen,
ähm und was sie aber nicht sehen ist, dass äh der Kommissionsvorschlag halt wirklich einige Stolperfallen beinhaltet, die man ausräumen muss, ansonsten äh kann man sich die Netzwerkität schenken, ansonsten legalisiert man,
die Diskriminierung im Netzwerk, die es an manchen Ländern sowieso schon gibt.
Und ähm wir wollen eben aufzeigen, äh wie vor allem bei den Liberalen jetzt gerade ähm so einige Tendenzen wirklich in die falsche Richtung gehen. Und ähm,
wie halt nicht verstanden wird, dass man eigentlich von der Kommission hinters Licht geführt wurde. Ähm also ähm bei bei den Liberalen haben wir Jens Rode aus den Shadow-Berichterstatter, das ist sozusagen derjenige, der.
Die Meinung der Gruppe definiert ähm und ähm da gibt's aus Deutschland auch einen Abgeordneten übrigens im Industrieausschuss, den Jürgen Kreuzmann,
und äh das sind halt alles wirklich so Hardliner.
Also jetzt Rode klingt natürlich schon mal deutsch, aber ist äh Däne. Mhm.
Genau, der ist denen und ähm das sind halt so Leute, mit denen kann man super über Netznetralität reden, die nicken auch die ganze Zeit und am Ende sagen sie aber, ja, aber Telkos müssen Geld verdienen.
Es hat auch eine Realität. Und ähm die Strategie dahinter ist auch ähm wie ich, glaube ich, in den vorherigen Folgen schon gesagt hat, immer noch so.
Wir nehmen den Tellkus äh das Roaming weg, da verlieren die Geld und deswegen erlauben wir ihnen halt, im Netzwerk zu diskriminieren,
und da sollen sie sich das Geld wieder zurückholen. Das heißt, dieses Prinzip, das man aus dem Roaming entfernt, nämlich das äh sowas wie,
Terminierungsentgelte gibt, dass ich zahlen muss, wenn ich jemanden,
wenn ich angerufen werde, das wollen sie jetzt im Internet einführen, indem halt Netflix zahlen muss äh oder andere Dienste zahlen müssen, wenn sie zu den Kunden dieses äh Eisbärs äh Zugang haben wollen.
Ja. Doppelt doppelt bezahlen sozusagen.
Genau und die die Artikel, die die wir bei Edri schreiben, äh sind halt hauptsächlich auch ähm für.
Politischen Zirkel, die uns äh sehr genau beobachten. Also, Etri hat sich über die mehr als zehnjährige Geschichte seines Bestehens, hat jetzt schon eine gewisse Position erarbeitet in diesem.
Brüsseler Politikparkett und ähm ich finde irgendwie das Schönste.
Der dir das schönste Zitat kam eh von der Euro-Ispa zu diesem Thema, ja, Edri wäre wirklich sehr gefährlich, wären Sie nicht so unterfinanziert.
Was ist Euro istpaar.
Euro istbar ist äh der europäische Verbund von Internetservicebewaldung.
Also da das sind äh die deutschen Telekoms und die ganzen Internet-Provider der Welt drin, äh die Europas drin, aber auch solche Filme wie Microsoft zum Beispiel.
Sozusagen die Internetwirtschaft.
Ah, verstehe. Das.
Versucht halt wirklich so diesen parlamentarischen Prozess in jeder Stufe zu begleiten. Und äh wir versuchen auch drüber zu berichten und gleichzeitig aber auch die die Öffentlichkeit immer zu informieren und mitzunehmen,
weil am Ende, wir haben halt nichts anderes als unsere Argumente und ähm eine Öffentlichkeit, die hinter uns steht oder nicht. Wir haben keine Geldkoffer.
Ja, also da wird mit harten Bandagen äh gekämpft irgendwie, unter anderem wurde auch schon äh euch Kommunismus vorgeworfen, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ah ja, das war auch wunderbar. Das ist äh der besagte, liberale Jens Rode.
Ähm der uns äh Netz Kommunismus vorgeworfen hat
weil unser Modell von Netzneutralität, das ist ja absoluter Kommunismus, wenn alle irgendwie dieselbe Leitung nutzen können, zur selben Bedingungen und sich keiner einen Vorteil kaufen kann, dann ist das doch ganz klar Kommunismus
Wettbewerb nennen. Ähm das ist unsere Meinung, er sieht das anders, obwohl er ein Liberaler ist.
Also ähm wie gesagt, die Liberalen sind hier wirklich das Zumischen an der Waage und die können die Mehrheiten shiften an dieser Stelle.
Und deswegen ist es sehr wichtig, dass man denen jetzt irgendwie erklärt, dass sie eigentlich gegen ihr eigenes Grundprinzip handeln, dass sie.
Ähm das, was ihnen eigentlich am Herzen liegen sollte, nämlich ähm Startups, kleine, mittelständische Unternehmen
niedrige Markteintrittsbarrieren und ganz einfach Wettbewerb, dass sie das hier auch abschaffen, wenn sie die Netzneutralität opfern für Roaming.
Ja, Netzkommunismus finde ich ja eigentlich gar nicht jetzt so einen schlechten Begriff, ne? Muss man sich ja nicht für schämen.
Ach so, ich meine.
Nicht persönlich genannt worden.
Ja, die Assoziation, die, die jetzt in den Köpfen dann natürlich damit erzeugt werden sollte, sonst äh natürlich klar, ne, aber in gewisser Hinsicht geht's hier natürlich schon auch um so eine Kommunalisierung, beziehungsweise einen eben zur Verfügung stehen von allen. Da kann ich nur sagen, na äh und wenn schon, ne.
Na ja, wie auch immer. Also auf jeden Fall, the fight ist going on. Die Grünen haben's jetzt äh verzögert. Es gibt jetzt eine Möglichkeit, noch mal Einfluss äh zu nehmen. Klingt für mich aber jetzt nicht unbedingt so, als ob.
Da wie soll ich sagen, eine Einflussnahmebereitschaft äh existiert bei diesen Ausschuss äh Mitgliedern oder muss man das etwas differenzierter betrachten?
Ja, also ich meine, wir wir müssen jetzt einfach die Zeit nutzen, die in zwei Wochen, die wir jetzt noch haben bis zum achtzehnten März,
Und äh müssen einfach noch viel breiter werden. Und äh wir müssen es schaffen, dass diese Kampagne noch ordentlich an Fahrt aufgewinnt. Äh im deutschsprachigen Raum haben wir das eigentlich schon sehr gut geschafft.
In Frankreich auch, dank in den anderen Ländern fiel's noch so ein bisschen an Multiplikatoren.
Muss halt einfach auch,
wirklich die Wahlen und die Konsequenzen so einer Entscheidung den gesamten Parteien ins Bewusstsein rufen, also die wollen äh einen Großteil der Abgeordneten will wiedergewählt werden im Mai,
und es schaut irgendwie schlecht aus äh in ihm Resümee, wenn sie kurz davor nochmal das freie Internet abschaffen.
Äh zu zu dieser Einstellung von äh Jens Rohde ist eigentlich eher am schönsten,
ähm was er in in diesem Facebook-Post, auf den sich dieses Netkommunissen äh der Netkommuniz im Artikel von Edri bezieht. Äh das sagt er ja auch, dass er nicht von einer Akta-Bewegung kontrolliert werden will.
Also äh ihm ist bewusst, dass das irgendwie jetzt das Internet ist, dass sich zu Wort meldet und er vergleicht das selbst mit Akte.
Zur Erinnerung, er hat damals auch gegen Akte gestimmt, ähm aber sozusagen, man man will sich ja einfach nicht reinlegen lassen. Die Argumente, die von der Gegenseite kommen, werden immer fadenscheiniger.
Und ähm man muss sich jetzt wirklich eher an die Leute wenden, die auf den Kandidatenlisten dieser Parteien sind. Und man muss die fragen, ob sie jetzt wirklich äh das vertreten können, was da gerade passiert.
Die sind jetzt alle schon im Wahlkampf, die sind alle erreichbar, ein Großteil von denen hat Twitter, Accounts ist auf Facebook.
Hat schon Telefonnummern, wo man sie erreichen kann? Das ist jetzt der beste Weg, um noch etwas an der Abstimmung im Ausschuss zu verändern.
Wie gesagt, die waren noch nie so offen gegenüber ihren Wählerinnen und Wählern wie jetzt und das ist unser Vorteil, die müssen wir ausnutzen.
Verstehe also im Prinzip äh die Empfehlung äh an die Hörer ist äh doch mal schnell ein Look abzumachen mit der äh äh Postleitzahl beziehungsweise Wahlkreis äh Kennung und mal nachzuschlagen, was denn eigentlich so der,
Abgeordnete äh ist der zuletzt gewählt wurde in diesem Segment. Also in diesem Wahlkreis.
Und da mal zu schauen, äh welche Kontaktmöglichkeiten es gibt, wird auf jeden Fall eine Telefonnummer geben, wird auf jeden Fall auch äh irgendwelche elektronischen Möglichkeiten geben und dann einfach eine dezente, individuelle Nachricht äh platzieren, wo man zum Ausdruck,
bringt, wie man das gerne hätte.
Ja und diese Kandidatenlisten, die sind ja, glaube ich, großteils jetzt schon fertiggestellt und öffentlich und die Kandidaten präsentieren sich ja auch im Netz ähm mit ganz schönen Profilen und Kontaktmöglichkeiten und das ist der beste, erste Anlaufpunkt.
Ich meine, interessant ist es natürlich in dem Zusammenhang eigentlich nur jetzt bei Parlamentsmitgliedern, die auch wieder antreten.
Genau, ähm aber auch vielleicht bei denen, die wieder reinkommen, weil im Grunde die Parteien können ja auch Druck auf ausüben, aufeinander,
Ähm wie gesagt, da äh wär's jetzt eigentlich wirklich mal an der Zeit, äh den klar zu machen, dass sie nicht äh so so eine Entscheidung fällen können,
vor der Wahl und nicht erwarten, dass das Internet äh da auch noch was mitzureden hat.
Genau, die Actab Bewegung,
Ja, naja gut, also letztlich ist es ja aber auch so, also sehen wir, wenn wir jetzt mal vom Schlimmsten ausgehen, dass dieser Ausschuss sagt, na hier eine Neutralität, ihr könnt mich mal und äh dann auch das Plenum des äh Europäischen Parlaments das entsprechend äh beschließt,
Ähm das bedeutet ja dann auch, dass ja quasi die erste Lesung jetzt, ne, also das ist die erste Runde.
Jein, also
wenn wenn die erste Lesung ähm mal beschlossen ist, dann ist das Parlament eigentlich schon sehr stark festgelegt in der Meinung, die es haben kann. Ähm wenn
die drei äh Gremien, also Kommission, Rat und Parlament sich mal festgelegt haben, dann ist sozusagen in dem Bereich muss dann ein Kompromiss gefunden werden,
dann können die nicht nochmal irgendwie äh in eine Richtung ausscheren, die in die die andere nicht schon gegangen sind.
Und gerade in der Frage der Netzzentralität würde ich jetzt nicht drauf vertrauen, dass die Staats- und Regierungschefs im Europarat äh da eine besonders progressive Position einnehmen werden
Ähm und deswegen wär's wirklich auch noch wichtig, dann sogar wenn wir itreve verlieren, den Industrieausschuss am am äh vierzehnten, äh dass wir dann,
die die Abstimmung am ersten April im Plenum nochmal voll ausnutzen und dann sind wir auch nicht mehr beschränkt auf dieses sehr nicht repräsentative Sample am industriefreundlichen Abgeordneten, sondern dann haben wir das große Plenum,
Das sind zwar auch viel mehr Leute, es sind über siebenhundert Abgeordnete, aber ähm da kann man dann auch nochmal mit einer anderen Art von Kampagne auf die zugehen.
Noch mal eine Frage bezüglich des Nachklopfens bei den Abgeordneten. Ich meine, wenn man da jetzt eine Mail hinschreibt und sagt, äh ich möchte gerne, dass die Netzneutralität gewahrt wird, dann könnten die ja in ihrer Logik sagen, ja kein Problem,
Wir waren die Netzneutralität, ja? Aber äh wir haben ja noch unsere also meine Frage ist.
Welche Formulierung gegenüber einem solchen Abgeordneten im Kontext des aktuellen Neusprech, der da so herrscht.
Bringt sagen wir mal die Position auch richtig zum Ausdruck. Was, worauf sollte man sozusagen drängen oder worauf sollte man hinweisen.
Da ist es wirklich am besten, wenn man auf Safety Internet Punkt EU geht, wir sind noch gar nicht erwähnt haben, dass es nämlich die Kampagnenseite für eigentlich all das
und dort findet man äh so Kontaktmöglichkeiten und darunter auch nicht nur Telefon, sondern auch E-Mail und Fax.
Und äh da sind so Beispieltexte.
Sehr gut unserer Meinung nach die bestehenden Probleme aufzeigen, die es noch bei der Verordnung gibt. Ähm und die die Entscheidung jetzt gerade für für Abgeordneten im Industrieausschuss ist,
in drei Punkte kommuniziert. Das eine ist eben, dass die Definition von Special heißt Service,
so eng sein soll, dass da eben keine Dienste, die es auch im Internet gibt, beinhaltet sein sollen.
Dass man die eine Lücke schließen muss die im Artikel dreiundzwanzig fünf ist, wo,
ISPs erlaubt wird außerhalb von meiner monatlichen Datenvolumen mich trotzdem noch zu beschränken und gewisse Dienste zu bevorzugen oder andere zu blockieren.
Ähm und das dritte Problem ist das Netzwerk noch gar nicht bindend ist in dieser Verordnung.
Weil da eben nicht ähm das wird zwar so in einem Erwägungsgrund, in einem Kommentar für das Gesetz äh definiert,
aber nicht in den eigentlichen Artikeln und darauf muss man noch verweisen, damit das bindend wird. Das sind unsere drei Kernforderungen von dem derzeitigen Verhandlungsstand.
Ähm ein kleines Nebenproblem, was wir haben, ist, dass.
Diese Verschiebung der Abstimmung davor waren wir klar, es gab so zwei konkurrierende ähm Kompromissvorschläge.
Und äh wir waren eben ganz klar verdiente Sozialdemokraten, weil der eben besser war, auch nicht perfekt, aber besser.
Und äh so klar kann man jetzt eben nicht mal kommunizieren, weil wir wissen nicht mehr, ob ähm diese zwei Textvorschläge noch auf den Tisch liegen, ob es neue gibt, wie sich das alles gerade verhält
Es kommt mit unklar, weil äh da noch Chaos herrscht, aber die drei Punkte sollte man kommunizieren, weil das sind die drei Sachen, auf die die Abgeordneten schauen sollen.
Und ähm wenn wenn Edri da irgendwie neuen Kenntnisstand hat, was gerade Verhandlung ist, dann werden wir diese Beispieltexte immer up to date halten,
und da einfach äh jederzeit sozusagen die adäquate Message, die den Parlamentariern auch ähm wenn sie handeln wollen,
das Richtige in die Hand gibt, damit die einfach ähm ohne zu zögern das Richtige tun können.
Ihr habt da jetzt ein schönes äh Interface auf der Webseite, wo man sozusagen auch direkt in Kontakt treten kann, per E-Mail, per Telefon äh Anruf, was passiert da eigentlich, wenn ich da draufklicke? Geht hier.
Wenn du da auf Telefon klickst, dann dann kommt noch mal so ein Pop ab, da gibt's du deine Telefonnummer ein.
Und dann wirst du angerufen, äh hörst du die die charmante Stimme von Jeremy Simmerman, äh die die auch schon mal im Programm hatte, dem ähm,
ehemaligen Sprecher von und der äh fragt dich dann, ob du dir wirklich sicher bist und dann musst du die Raute Taste drücken und dann bist du schon verbunden mit dem Büro von dem Ab.
Verstehe, alles klar, so ein Netz passiert da äh dieses Jahr oder direkt eine E-Mail äh oder halt ein Fax. Da sind jetzt so vorformulierte Texte,
Ich denke, es ist durchaus sinnvoll, sich da seine eigene Formulierung auszu äh suchen, das schon mal ganz gut, dass ihr das Subjact schon mal freigelassen habt, dass man da.
Ich immer wieder dasselbe in der Inbox sieht, ne.
Sind auch so Sachen, äh die äh die gesamte Kampagne und auch all diese Kontakttools bis auf das Fontool, es nicht von uns, sind auch auf GITAP auf dem Gitter-Account von der Netzfreiheit ähm die das zu Großteil eben programmiert hat,
Und äh das ist auch alles Open Saurs. Wir entwickeln da die ganze Zeit weiter, verbessern das noch, zum Beispiel,
einfach nur den Standardtext wegschicken will, dann wird man jetzt auch nochmal gefragt, ob man sich da sicher ist, dass man nicht nochmal was ändern will, ähm weil eben personalisierte E-Mails und Faxe besser sind.
Und ähm ja, also das das ist auch so wirklich sehr lebendiges Open-Source, äh Developement und all diese Tools ähm sind auch unter freier Lizenz, damit sie noch woanders weiter verwendet werden können
insbesondere auf das Wachstum sind wir stolz, weil das ist halt irrsinnig schön, Internetausdrucker kompatibel.
Und das Nette ist auch äh die diese Fax-Geräte sind äh nicht nur äh ein bisschen laut, sondern die kann man auch nicht abschalten, weil die sind in dem Drucker integriert. Das heißt, die müssen ihren Drucker abstecken, damit sie keine Faxe mehr bekommen.
Verstehe. Okay, sinnvoll. Da linken wir da auf jeden Fall hier auch noch auf den Githup äh
wer Lust hat, sich da noch ein bisschen kurz zu holen, weil das scheint mir ja durchaus brauchbar auch für äh andere Kampagnen zu sein. Äh noch eine Frage dazu, äh
da kann man dann immer, gib mir mal einen anderen Abgeordneten, den ich ansprechen kann. Die werden so random mäßig ausgewählt, habt ihr jetzt nur diejenigen genommen, die tatsächlich in diesem Ausschuss äh sind oder geht das jetzt generell äh über alle?
Das sind jetzt mal nur die Abgeordneten im itrausschuss und es gibt auch noch äh so eine Wahrscheinlichkeit, nach der,
die bestimmt werden, also ähm dass wir zum Beispiel jetzt die Grünen, die eher auf unserer Seite sind, genauso wie die
also die linke und auch zum Teil die Sozialdemokraten, dass wir die mit einer niedrigeren Wahrscheinlichkeit anzeigen als die Konservativen und die Liberalen.
Mhm. Versterben.
Also, das ist alles, Jason im Hintergrund und ähm gibt's auch Skripte, die man im Gitarb sehen kann, mit denen wir diese Wahrscheinlichkeit vergeben, damit auch das irgendwie nachvollziehbar ist.
Und man auch da irgendwie drüber diskutieren kann, was die beste Strategie ist.
Maschinenlesbare Politiktendenz.
Maschinendisbacher Staat.
Maschinendesbacher Stadt, ja das wollten wir eigentlich immer haben, oder?
Ja, langsam kommt's, aber es ist weitaus schmerzvoller, als sich das alle jemals gedacht.
Gut. Ähm.
Super, dann äh viel Glück und alle, die hier zuhören sollten da mal draufklicken und mal gucken, was sie da noch zu beitragen können.
Ja
Wir bleiben beim Thema, wir machen äh heute hier mal ein Netzneutralitäts äh Spezial. Nächste Woche gehen wir dann wieder ein bisschen mehr in die Einzelmeldungen rein.
Ähm ist ja noch was anderes äh los gewesen.
Äh in den USA ist ein Deal bekannt geworden zwischen Comkas, einem der größten oder ist es sogar der größte Kabel.
Ich glaube, es.
Der größte Kabelnetzbetreiber meines Wissens nach und vor allem äh haben die ja grade irgendwie einen äh Mercher vorgeschlagen mit Time Warner,
der, glaube ich, der zweitgrößte ist, das heißt, die wollen, was sie mit großen Abstand zum allergrößten ähm Kabelnetzbetreiber in den USA machen würde,
man muss auch sagen, es gibt jetzt eigentlich schon ähm ein Monopol.
An einem Ort, an jedem Ort in den USA, weil du hast kaum äh Städte oder Punkte auf der Karte der USA, wo es mehr als einen Kabelnetzbetreiber gibt,
Ähm das heißt, da gibt's sowieso auch keine, keine Wahlfreiheit für die Kunden, dass sie irgendwie,
Anbieter wechseln können, wenn sie nicht zufrieden sind, da gibt's ja auch eine wunderschöne Saufparkfolge dazu, die man nur sehr empfehlen kann.
Welche?
Ich äh wir verlinken da drauf äh die die kann man wirklich sehr empfehlen, das äh zeigt sehr gut die groteske Logik von Monopolen im Kabelnetzbereich.
Und äh diese wirklich desaströse Situation, in die die USA sich da begeben haben, war sie halt ähm de facto Monopole haben, wenn man irgendwie Kabelfernsehen haben will und Internet, vor allem wenn man irgendwie schnelles Internet haben will.
Ja.
Dann kann man sowieso nur,
zum Kabelnetz gehen, weil über die Kupferleitungen kriegt man in den USA halt äh nichts, was irgendwie über sechzehn MBit ist. Und.
Das ist halt eine Situation, äh wo wo diese Firmen überhaupt keine Konkurrenz mehr haben. Das heißt, die Preise sind äh um ein Vielfaches teurer als im Rest der Welt
und die Bandbreiten, die sie einem anbieten, sind inzwischen schon so auf ähm ja
Entwicklungslandniveau kann man gar nicht sagen, weil es gibt manche Entwicklungsländer, die schon schnellere Bandbreiten anbieten als die, also die USA ist, ist in der Hinsicht, in ihrer Infrastruktur wirklich schon weit ins Hintertreffen geraten.
So und jetzt äh was ist mit diesem Deal zwischen Netflix und äh Koncast? Was genau wurde da äh bekannt?
Ja, also ähm es ähm,
wir erinnern uns noch, dass äh es ja eine Entscheidung gab, dass die Netzneutralitätsregelungen äh der FCC, der amerikanischen Regulierungsbehörde aufgehoben wurden von einem Höchstgericht
und seit das passiert ist, oh Wunder, oh Wunder, ah, haben die,
Geschwindigkeiten, die Netflix gemessen hat, äh mit denen seine Videos zu seinen Kunden ausliefern konnte, sind rapide in den Keller gegangen.
Und ähm nachdem die sich irgendwie wehren wollten dagegen, dass ihre Kunden auf einmal einen schlechten Dienst bekommen von ihnen,
Das ist aber nicht an ihnen lag, sondern an den Kabelnetzbetreibern.
Ähm äh ist Netflix jetzt nach langem Hin und Her in die Knie gegangen und zahlt jetzt dafür, dass ähm seine Daten in ausreichende Geschwindigkeit an die Kunden kommen.
Und das ist wie manche Kommentatoren meinen halt so das Ende der Netzautralität in den USA ähm,
von von einer wirtschaftlichen Seite ist es das auch, weil jetzt halt wirklich mal so,
dieser Kniefall gemacht wurde und große Inhalte, Anbieter übergehen, dafür zu bezahlen,
Weg Geld zu bezahlen, dass sie empfangen werden können äh von von ihren Kunden
Ähm und damit haben wir halt jetzt einfach ein ein Problem, das eigentlich schon über längere Zeit bestanden ist, nochmal in einer Dimension vor Augen geführt bekommen, dass man einfach sieht, dieser ganze,
interconnect Markt, also da wo,
ähm Eisbies untereinander Daten austauschen. Da haben wir halt ein großes Problem inzwischen, weil ähm die ISPs immer mehr merken, dass die da in einer Machtposition sind, dass sie Geld verlangen können,
das ja in den vorherigen Sendungen schon ausführlich behandelt äh mit diesen die immer mehr zunehmen,
Und äh ja, jetzt sind wir halt an einem Punkt angekommen, ähm wo das Eis bricht
und ähm wir wahrscheinlich in zunehmender Zahl ähm alle online Dienste, die viel Daten über die Leitung schicken, zur Kasse gebeten werden und das hat halt einfach mehrere Konsequenzen
Einerseits mal, das ist so etwas wie ein ein neues Netflix nicht mehr geben wird, weil.
Wie sollen die sich jemals durchsetzen, wenn sie um äh irgendwo erfolgreich zu sein, mal irgendwie.
Geld aufdrücken müssen für für den großen Incomeback dort, also für den ISP, der ihnen den Zugang zu diesen Kunden ermöglicht.
Und ähm auf der anderen Seite halt auch, dass diese ähm Eisbieß dann halt ähm die die Entscheidung treffen darüber, wer sich in diesem Markt durchsetzen kann und wer nicht und
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie diese diese Machtposition zum Vorteil ihrer Kunden ausnutzen werden.
Es ist für dich schon hochgradig bedenklich, vor allem so der ganze Neusprech, der damit verbunden ist, man sieht das ja hier in diesem offiziellen Statement von Comcast so. Ja, wir tun uns zusammen und äh it's all about the excellence User Experience und so, ja, weil das ist ja alles nur für die Kunden
Klar, so auf den ersten Blick kann man natürlich das äh irgendwie so auch auslegen, also zumindest wenn man jetzt mit den ähm,
Konzepten dahinter nicht so vertraut ist, aber langfristig bedeutet es schlicht
dass man also nicht nur nicht nur, dass man äh äh Schwierigkeiten hat, dass wenn man's jetzt drauf anlegt, mit seinem Startup da äh entsprechend gleich zu ziehen und schnell populär zu werden. Also angenommen, ich biete jetzt irgendeinen Dienst an, der an sich,
Bandbreiten intensiv ist und der auch wirklich jetzt von äh so einer Rildherm Auslieferung oder zumindest einer sehr schnellen Auslieferung abhängig ist.
Ich habe da wirklich jetzt was cooles Neues rausgefunden. Alle wollen das haben. Dann steigt halt meine Bandbreite einfach, weil's gut ist. So und die Leute nehmen's dann auch,
nachdem es populär geworden ist, noch als gut war, weil ich eben so skalieren kann. In dem Moment, wo ich aber erstmal zahlen muss, um ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt überhaupt.
Die Dienstgüte auch wahrnehmen lassen zu können, ja, also äh angenommen, ich habe jetzt tausend User, ich kann halt nicht mehr hinterher skalieren, ohne gleich
allen möglichen Providen. Es geht ja hier nicht nur um einen, ja, ist ja nicht so, dass man einen Provider dafür bezahlt, dass die Daten schnell ins Netz geht, wie man das zum Beispiel bei CDNs hat. Das ist ja eine ganz andere Situation. Ja, also wenn ich so ein, so ein, so ein Delivery Network verwende, dann,
beziehe ich hier eine explizite Dienstleistung, nämlich hier repliziert meine Daten, meine Streaming-Server, et cetera, leitet das durch euer Netzwerk schnell an verschiedene Verteilungspunkte, damit es eben schnell bei den ISPs ist, die letzten, die ich die Verbindung zu den Usern herstellen
nein hier müsste ich ja im Prinzip mit jedem einzelnen ISP weltweit oder zumindest jedem, der sich entsprechenden quer stellt oder so querstellen kann, weil er eben so ein Monopol hat, äh,
einigen und äh müsste vor allem auch alle pauschal irgendwie mit Unsummen bestechen. Das heißt, das ist schon mal einerseits nicht möglich. Andererseits bedeutet das auch,
Das andere Unternehmen ohne ihre Dienstgüte zu verbessern, schlicht und ergreifend durch so eine Bezahlung, ja,
Andere auch raushalten können. Faktisch, weil die nicht in der Lage sind, finanziell entsprechend nachzuziehen oder niemand bereit wäre, das äh entsprechend zu ähm das Investment bereitzustellen. Also es ist schon wirklich sehr beunruhigend und äh.
Mich daran wirklich immer wieder sehr stört ist. Und ich frage mich, dass wir auch nochmal eine Frage an dich. Wenn jetzt grade sich solche liberalen,
Gruppen. Also ich meine, mit liberal ist ein bisschen schwierig. Ich glaube, wir denken da so primär an FDP. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auf europäischer Ebene auch so ein ähnliches äh Mindset ist, aber äh.
Ganz schwierig. Da gibt's eigentlich keine es gibt nicht mal innerhalb der liberalen Gruppe eine einheitliche Definition von dem, was liberal ist. Das wissen sie selbst nicht.
Ja okay, aber ich ich würde ihnen zumindest mal eine gewisse privatwirtschaftliche Nähe oder Nähe ist vielleicht Affinität.
Vermutung kann man, ja.
Ja, so also befassen sich mehr mit mit äh der Realität von Firmen, als es jetzt, was weiß ich, vielleicht die Linken äh tun. So.
So der Markt als Konzept und als Antwort.
Genau, so und eigentlich ich meine, ich finde es auch bemerkenswert, dass dieser Jens Rohde da jetzt sozusagen gegen den Kommunismus schießt,
Ja? Also da auch wirklich solche äh Kampfwörter äh an Start nimmt, ja, sozusagen in der Hoffnung auf freie Märkte jetzt mal so als,
als Gegenthese zu Kommunismus, ja, dass wir das ja mal gerne hahnen geführt wird, aber eigentlich ja mit so einer.
Genau Monopolisierung.
Fördert und gerade einen freien Markt im Sinne von.
Einfacher Zugang auch für neue äh Mitspieler äh verhindert. Ich freue mich, ob das in der politischen Argumentation auch eine ob man das irgendwie so auch in die Köpfe reinbekommt oder ob das einfach nicht klickt.
Also ähm
wenn's wenn's drum geht, liberaler zu überzeugen, wir wir probieren das die ganze Zeit, also wir haben jetzt eigentlich auch ähm, das ist mir auch immer ein Anliegen, das Netzzentralität kann man Irrsinn nicht schön für solche Leute freamen, weil es halt auch wirklich de facto,
eigentlich eine eine Absicherung eines eines freien Marktes ist, eines Wettbewerbs ist und gerade eben die Startups, die äh Unternehmen, die in Europa vielleicht auch mal ein Gegengewicht zu den amerikanischen Monopolisten aufbauen könnten.
Fördern würde. Das heißt, es wäre sogar Makroökonomisch genauso wie lokal-ökonomisch sinnvoll für Europa, da auf Netzneutralität zu setzen, weil das ist einer der wenigen Wirtschaftsbereiche, der überhaupt noch wächst.
Das sind alles Argumente, ähm die, die man ähm ja, immer wieder reinhämmern muss in der Hoffnung, dass sie irgendwann einmal greifen,
ich sag's nochmal, Jürgen Kreuzmann ist der FDP-Politiker, der im Ausschuss sitzt und erzählt eindeutig zu den Hardliner, sogar innerhalb der alte Fraktion ist er derjenige, der,
ähm die die skurrilsten Änderungsanträge eingebracht hat und der sich auch äh von dem, was wir hören,
in den Diskussionen ähm so sehr am am stärksten an.
Dem Kommissionsvorschlag orientiert und der am liebsten gar nichts geändert hätte daran. Also wenn man jemanden anrufen will, dann wäre das zum Beispiel so so ein Kandidat.
Ich wollte aber noch auf was anderes einsteigen, was du gesagt hast mit diesem Content Living Networks. Die haben,
lange Zeit als äh Mittelman fungiert und äh so irgendwie diesen Konflikt ein bisschen,
vom Eskalieren abgehalten in dem Netflix ja auch zum Beispiel lange Zeit bei so einem war um dort.
Einfach seinen Traffic von denen vorleiert, vorhalten zu lassen. Apple macht das ja auch mit Ackermai, das kennt man.
Nur haben wir jetzt halt auch immer mehr die Situation, dass die Internet-Provider, die ja auch immer weniger werden, ähm immer größere Konglomerate von ISPs, die sich zusammenschließen mit immer mehr Kundenbasis,
halt einfach wirklich ihre Kunden als Faustpfand in den Verhandlungen verwenden und direkt gegenüber,
Anbietern gehen. Direkt gegenüber Netflix, wahrscheinlich auch in irgendeiner Form direkt gegenüber Apple stehen.
Von denen halt einfach mal Kohle abzukassieren und durch den fehlenden Wettbewerb auf der einen Seite, dass wir einfach im äh Internet äh Zugangsanbietermarkt
immer weniger Player haben, weil die sich alle untereinander aufkaufen und auch auf dem,
Inhalt der Anbietermarkt äh immer weniger Wettbewerb äh äh kristallisiert sich halt zu einer Situation heraus, wo die einen ganz klar in der Machtposition sind
und die anderen es sich auch langsam leisten können für den Erhalt ihrer Monopolistensituation. Ein bisschen Geld abzudrücken, um sich für alle Zeiten die Konkurrenz vom Haus zu halten.
Ja. Also man man baut eigentlich Monopole auf beiden Seiten auf.
Deswegen ist unsere Argumentation aus, dass man Special als Services ganz klar ganz hart definieren muss,
weil ansonsten bestärkt man Monopole, ansonsten fördert man Monopole. Das ist eine klare Beziehung. Und äh
das das geht auch in so vielen äh Punkten gegen die Grundlagen des Internets. Also
wenn wenn man sich das mal zu Ende denkt, dann äh können wir auch das Ende zu Ende Prinzip vergessen, also dass ich von jedem Punkt im Internet, zu jedem anderen Punkt im Internet eine Verbindung aufbauen kann,
dann muss ich halt einfach in einer Welt ohne Netzzentralität zuerst Geld abdrücken, bevor ich diesen Videostreaming-Dienstleister verwenden kann.
Und
damit haben wir nicht mehr ein Internet, sondern Mininetz und eine eine Zersplitterung, eine Segmentierung des Netzes,
kommt diese eine wunderschönere Folge vom Reporter ohne ähm elektrischen Reporter wieder in den Kopf, äh die verlinken wir am besten auch. Da wurde dieses Szenario mal vorgezeigt. Das ist so irgendwie von der Abschaffung der Netzneutralität
über diese Fragmentierung bis hin zu kleinen kommerziellen Netzen und dem kompletten Abschalten des Internets, also die haben die Dystopie mal bis zu Ende gezeichnet.
Ja
Ja, alles nicht so schön, aber noch äh ist äh hier der Drops nicht gelutscht und von daher kann hier jeder mit äh einsteigen.
Als.
Und letzten Punkt, können wir nochmal ein anderes äh wiederum Netzneutralität gelagertes äh Thema machen. Jetzt war ja gerade der Mobile World Kongress in Barcelona. Ist jetzt eigentlich schon vorbei? Ja, ne, ist vorbei, ne?
Keine Ahnung, ich habe nur heute irgendwie ähm im Fernsehen gesehen, dass er war.
Ja. Ähm so, da gab's, äh das habe ich aber nicht gesehen, aber du hast es wahrscheinlich mitbekommen, äh glaube ich, auch eine Keynote von Herrn äh Zuckerberg, dem Facebook Chef.
Ja, der hat sich da irgendwie zu Wort gemeldet und hat da auch gleich irgendwie seine äh sein neuestes Pad dabei, ähm die Leute von äh wie hießen die nochmal WhatsApp?
Und ähm ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie.
Eine Kampfansage war also ich habe mir schon im Vorfeld gedacht irgendwie, dass das wahrscheinlich recht ein Reizthema ist, wenn,
Whatsapp, was ja so die Kannibalisierung des SMS-Umsatzes für einen Großteil der,
Telekomfirmen ist, die auf diesem Mobile World Summit sind, um sich untereinander zu vernetzen, wenn der dort ist und äh ihnen die Keynote gibt. Aber wir sehen halt an der Stelle so ein bisschen.
Davon, ähm dass dass die durchaus eben eher mal dies abschließen, anstatt sich gegenseitig zu bekriegen
und ähm was was äh dort eben ganz groß Thema war, ist eine ähm neues Projekt von von Zuckerberg äh Internet Punkt org,
Und äh das ist eigentlich das, was wir schon von Facebook Zero kennen, aber nochmal mit einem riesigen äh fetten Schicht an PR Marketing und jetzt lasst uns die Welt besser machen.
Wenn man irgendwie einen guten Magen hat, dann kann man sich dieses Video anschauen.
Ähm auf jeden Fall, also zumindest mit derselben Aufmerksamkeit schauen, wie wie Russia Today, also da da gibt's sehr viele kleine Close drinnen.
Und ähm ja, im Grunde äh ist es halt auch dort äh das Stichwort vertikale Integration.
Man will seine Dienste möglichst ähm nicht mehr so auf diesem Internet anbieten, sondern man will irgendwie ein Produkt haben.
Das ist irgendwie ein Inhalt der Anbieter gibt der den Zugang regelt und am besten auch noch direkt auf der Hardware vorinstalliert ist, das heißt ich habe Facebook,
Das habe ich äh ohne, dass ich Internet auf meinem Telefon habe, in der Form von Internet Punkt org oder Facebook Zero,
gratis einfach dabei in einer abgespeckten Variante und dann halt auch noch auf dem Telefon eine eine Anwendung, die mir ermöglicht, das zu nutzen,
Daten dort herzugeben, auch wenn ich vielleicht in einem Land lebe, wo wo Internet maximal in irgendwelchen Internetcafis zur Verfügung steht.
Die Strategie dahinter ist für Facebook ganz klar, dass sie ihre.
Kundschaft kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht sagen. Die Menschen, über die sie Daten sammeln, auch ausweiten will über die Leute, die sich ja wirklich am wenigsten wehren können. Nämlich ähm Menschen in Entwicklungsländern.
Also die Ansage ist auch so irgendwie jetzt äh let's connect äh the next Billion People.
Man will ja einfach mehr Leute ins Netz bringen, aber man meint damit nicht das Internet, sondern Facebook,
und die Daten, die über die Leute gesammelt werden, verwendet Facebook natürlich so, wie sie alle Daten verwendet von Leuten, ähm nämlich für Werbezwecke.
Weiß Gott für was andere Dinge noch, das heißt da da ist halt so grade jetzt ja das das zeichnet sich am Horizont ab
und ähm in entwickelten Ländern äh ist das äh vielleicht,
nicht etwas über das wir uns Sorgen machen müssen, aber an andererseits auch hier gibt es Leute, die sich vielleicht kein äh Gigabyte äh Internet leisten können und äh für deren Wertkarten, SIM Karten wird's genauso auch ähm,
solche Angebote geben. Und da muss man sich halt wirklich die Frage stellen, was passiert, wenn,
Wir nicht mehr davon ausgehen können, dass äh die Leute Internet haben, sondern dass sie halt wirklich nur noch Facebook Zugang haben.
Ja, das Ganze läuft ja, glaube ich, hinter dem Begriff äh Facebook Zero, ne? Das scheint so ein bisschen der sich äh äh etablierende Terminus zu sein für solche Dienste. Das gibt's ja auch schon bei Wikipedia. Wikipedia Zero
haben wir ja, glaube ich, auch schon mal drüber gesprochen. Ähm was ja auch, sagen wir mal,
debattierungswürdig ist, bei Wikipedia äh haut man halt äh gerne nicht äh nicht so gerne drauf, weil da jetzt nicht unbedingt äh so ein Cottbus dahinter steht, der äh Daten sammelt, äh Profile auswertet und äh Werbung verkauft, ja?
Nur in dem Moment, wo man sich natürlich Wikipedia in solche äh Sachen ein äh binden lässt, ähm ja ist vielleicht die
Die Alternative Wikipedia, die wir vielleicht auch irgendwann nochmal brauchen, sozusagen auch schon wieder benachteiligt. Also es ist einfach immer so dieser dieser äh freie Zugang und dieses Argument mit na ja, wir machen das ja billiger für euch. Ja, das ist halt wieder dieses Ding mit äh
nur weil es erstmal kostenlos ist, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass es äh für euch die bessere Wahl ist.
Also ähm Wikipedia ist an der Stelle auch meiner Meinung nach ähm
nicht gerecht gegenüber dem, was Wikipedia möglich gemacht hat, nämlich ähm ein freies, offenes und neutrales Internet, also Wikipedia hätte es niemals geschafft, so eine Verbreitung zu finden
wer da nicht irgendwie ein ein neutrales Internet gewesen was den Zugang ermöglicht hätte und dass sie selbst gegen dieses Prinzip verstoßen,
ist einfach kurzsichtig. Und auch kurzsichtig von der Wikimedia Foundation, dass sie,
ähm nicht verstehen, dass sie damit eigentlich die Grundlage zerstören, die ihr eigenes Kernprojekt überhaupt erst möglich gemacht hat.
Deswegen wäre die eigentliche und einzige verantwortungsvolle Entscheidung, Wikipedia Zero abzuschalten in allen Ländern.
Und ähm sich für Netznetralität einzusetzen und für den Netzausbau in Entwicklungsländern.
Ja, na gut, äh unabhängig davon ähm
Was ja dahinter steht, ist dieses Bundling und das ist ja auch in dieser ganzen Netzneutralitätsdiskussion äh auch ein festes Thema, haben wir jetzt so noch gar nicht äh angerissen, aber man äh sieht das ja jetzt hier auch in Deutschland, ja, diese äh ja hier, du kriegst halt da den Zugang und äh vor allem
wir hier für den deutschen europäischen Raum immer von so Schreckgespenstern reden
in Asien und so weiter ist das auch schon durchaus Gang und Gebe. Also da gibt es sehr wohl solche gestaffelten Angebote, wo man irgendwie so einen niedrigen Preis zahlt und in diesem niedrigen Preis ist aber dann schon Facebook mit drin und das ist noch mit drin und das ist,
drin. Also der der Zugang wird da auch über den Preis schon von vornherein aussortiert, was ja dann letzten Endes auch bedeutet,
quasi man sich eben für diesen Einstiegspreis, ja, äh quasi ein Netz erkauft, was ja,
sag mal, bisschen hart äh vorzensiert ist, ja, weil einfach Dinge abgeschaltet sind, also ein aktiver Eingriff äh in,
eigentliche Datenverbindung stattfindet.
Also so ein Whitelist Internet, das ist eigentlich das Problem, ne? Also man man man darf quasi nur äh das benutzen, was äh äh freigeschaltet ist.
Und die letzte Stufe, egal wie viel Stufen man hat, ja, das mit Abstand teuerste ist quasi der freie Zugang.
Entsprechend wird halt den freien Zugang so dann wahrscheinlich auch kaum noch jemanden wählen und äh
ja, dann könnte man so Gespräche haben wie, na ja, hier, geh doch mal auf die Webseite und so weiter, Handy, das habe ich nicht in meinem Tarif, kann ich mir nicht angucken, interessiert mich nicht mit zu teuer.
So und das so haben wir das Internet nicht kennengelernt, ja. Ich meine, das ist dann irgendwie Internetsero, das ist dann irgendwie einfach nichts mehr drin.
Ja und ich meine, da muss man sich auch immer einfach irgendwie nur nur fünf Jahre oder zehn Jahre in die Zukunft versetzen. Ich meine, wenn wir.
Mal die Verwendung von Internet ein bisschen hochskalieren und dran denken, dass äh wahrscheinlich irgendwie,
drei Dinge in unserer Tasche und zwei Dinge an unserem Körper ständig eine Internetverbindung haben werden,
Und ähm dass dass wir weitaus vernetzter sein werden und weitaus mehr,
Daten hin und her schicken werden und dass dann zum Beispiel auch irgendwie so E-Health äh Anwendungen,
ähm die ja durchaus sinnvoll sein könnten für manche Menschen, ähm dass die dann halt auch irgendwie bei der einen ähm.
Gesundheitsversicherung ähm angeboten werden und bei der anderen muss ich mich dann irgendwie noch um meinen Dataplan kümmern. Ja, also,
es gibt da eine eine Vielzahl an Szenarien, die man sich vorstellen kann, wo wo das Ganze hinführt, wo diese Ungerechtigkeit halt noch einfach äh viel größer wird. Wir reden halt hier nicht von,
von von Flugzeugtickets, wo's ganz normal für uns inzwischen ganz normal ist, wenn es eine Economy Class, eine Business Class und eine erste class gibt, sondern,
hier halt wirklich von einer Infrastruktur, die gesellschaftliche Teilhabe ermöglichen soll, die,
uns überhaupt erstmal in in vielen Fällen äh eine Teilnahme an Demokratie ermöglicht und.
Wie ihr auch gesehen haben eine Möglichkeit ist, Protest zu organisieren und uns überhaupt noch Gehör zu verschaffen,
und wenn wir das aufs Spiel setzen, nur weil es jetzt gerade Firmen gibt, die sich denken, okay.
Nicht genügend Geld, nicht genügend, wie ich mir vorstelle, dass das sein soll, aber äh diese amerikanischen Firma da drüben, die die machen Milliardenumsätze und deswegen will ich was von diesem Stück Kuchen haben.
Oder weil Unternehmen sagen, ja, ich investiere nicht in meine Netze, wenn der Staat mir mein Geld äh kein Geld mehr gibt, dann äh soll er dafür sorgen, dass ich es mir von anderen holen kann.
Müssen wir diesen Tendenzen halt Einhalt gebieten. Also es es kommt jetzt hier langsam äh auf einer Grundsatzfrage hinaus, die ja auch eigentlich eine zutiefst politische Frage ist.
Wir stehen heute leider wie an vielen Stellen, zum Beispiel auch Datenschutz äh genau an diesem Wendepunkt,
dass wenn wir hier Standard setzen wollen, die äh irgendwie weltweit noch äh überhaupt eine eine Chance haben zu existieren, dann müssen wir das auf einem europäischen Level machen.
Also Europa ist ähm wirklich für mich aus tiefster Überzeugung. Der einzige Punkt, wo wir Grundrechte noch in Stein meißeln können,
Nationalstaatlicher Ebene sehen wir einfach nur, wie die Stück für Stück ausgehöhlt werden,
Und wenn wir es jetzt schaffen, auf europäischer Ebene diesen Vlog einzuschlagen und einfach klar zu sagen, Internet hat so zu sein und das ist ein Grundwert und der muss erhalten bleiben,
dann haben wir auch ähm die Chance, eine Vorbildrolle einzunehmen als Friedensnobelpreisträger Europa.
Dann haben wir eine Chance, noch ein Beispiel zu setzen, dass es auch anders gehen kann und dass es auch noch andere Werte gibt, als äh die der Wirtschaft. Und.
Die Entscheidung muss halt jetzt getroffen werden und meiner Meinung nach sollte das auch eine der zentralen Fragen sein für diese Europawahl im Mai.
Schön gesagt, Thomas, denke äh, jetzt können wir hier auch ähm diese Änderung zu einem gluriosen äh Ende führen, beziehungsweise haben das schon getan. Äh.
Vielleicht kannst du ja auch noch ein paar Kurzentschlossene Praktikanten gebrauchen, die jetzt auch noch der Meinung sind, mal jetzt alle Zelte abzubrechen mit unklarer Zukunftsaussicht, wäre genau das Richtige in ihrem Leben.
Ja das das das Büro hier ist schon recht voll.
So
Ähm ja, also ich ich kann da irgendwie ähm wer nach Brüssel kommen will und hier wirklich ähm.
Was bewegen will, der soll zu Edri kommen. Das ist echt einer der geilsten Organisationen, die ich hier kennenlernen durfte und ähm die die vergangenen,
zwei, drei Wochen waren die anstrengendsten meines Lebens, aber auch die äh gewinnbringendsten, die schönsten, die tragischsten und ähm.
Ja, hier kann man halt wirklich noch was bewegen. Und ähm deswegen äh wer sonst irgendwie bei der Kampagne mitmachen will, äh soll mir irgendwie eine Mail schreiben oder auf Twitter mich anschreiben. Wir haben wirklich irrsinnig viel zu tun, was äh wo man uns helfen kann.
Wenn's nur Kaffee kochen ist.
Nee, das schaffen wir noch alleine, also.
Da seid ihr noch nicht richtig ausgelastet.
Nein, okay. Jeder kann mitmachen. Super. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Brüssel und äh ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war das Logbuch. Nächste Woche gibt's äh wahrscheinlich einen anderen äh Überraschungsgast und äh lasst euch aber auch mal entsprechend überraschen und äh irgendwann kommt dann auch Linus wieder. Bis dahin sage ich äh tschüss und bis bald.
Tschau, tschau.